Now that your done with the lectures, it's not the end.
One of the things you might consider doing is putting together a lessons learned presentation.
This summarizes everything you learned week to week either by watching the lectures
or hopefully getting out of the building and talking to customers.
What to do with that presentation?
Well number 1 is you could post it to the forums, and we'll select the best presentations
and put them on Steve's blog.
The second is you might use this as a prototype
for actually thinking about how to talk to investors and how to talk to other customers.
But what do you do next after this class really depends on you.
One is, it could have been a good exercise for you to decide whether
entrepreneurship is for you or not.
Next could have been is you've decided whether your idea is worth pursuing or not.
Third is, if you have and you still like your team members after getting out of the building
and working hard, you could decide that the next step might actually be to pursue this idea
either in an incubator, an accelorator, trying to raise some funds,
or trying to take the company to the next step.
What I hope is this class gave you a small taste of what entrepreneurship feels like,
and what are the things you need to do.
There is a ton more to learn. Take a look at the rest of the Udacity courses.
Take a look at steveblank.com and Alexander Osterwalder's website,
businessmodelgeneration.com.
I also recommend checking out startupweekend.org
for other events and other courses, and we'll see you when you're a public company.